Sophia Ricci is finally dishin on her
relationship with Justin Bieber
what do you the 18 year old is on one of
two covers of billboard style issue
she looks white hot in this sexy
mid-drift fairing look and here's what
she said about her romance with the
Biebs quote we have a special
relationship justin is very easy to talk
to and that's hard to find with people
in Los Angeles being true to myself
always as for the media circus that
surrounded her since she was first
linked to Justin she's cool with it
quote I'm going to be real with you it
doesn't bother me as long as I'm happy
Sophia also dishes on her edgy style I
will go crazy in the guy section with
the hoodies and reveals she sometimes
has to give her dad Lionel a few fashion
pointers sometimes he'll be leaving the
house looking a little crazy and I'll
have to tell him to go change okay guys
let's talk all things Jo via
over on twitter let me know if you like
them if you're not into them and of
course stick with ET online for all the
latest
[Music]
you